then the room is a bit empty but
I hope someone will come back every day
my name is dario I have been working in google
for six years since everyone is
announcing their art miur works
in google play console so not
directly in the cloud of work with the
cloud team  in my 20 percent is the
play console the system we use
to allow developers to
distribute their android applications
on the play store I deal with a part of
analytics so I use the
internal version of many of these
big data tools that we will present later
in the video presentation on stage
michele furio di menard who
will also present as main ad
uses the google tools of the
google cloud platform to solve the
critical problems of their business
during the presentation there will be
some concepts already expressed in
previous presentations so I will go to a
little more glister or about some of these
concepts
if you then have any questions  in
particular it reaches themes after the
presentation google's mission as
many will already know and to organize
global information making it
universally accessible and useful is
the main example of how
we say we perform this mission is clearly
the search engine that we also use
here as an example  of application that has
to do with big data
the challenges of a search engine on
a global scale are certainly how to
store this data how to store
this data so what storage solutions to
adopt to store large
amounts of data in this case we are talking about
peta method of reading exabytes of data
from the internet
once it stores this data a
big problem as mentioned by da
mattia in the previous presentation and
how to process
this data and then adopt
solutions that allow you to manage and
process data on a large scale both
in  we say static way is
dynamic online way in the form of st  ream and
finally once these data have
been processed
no a challenger provide this data
in the form of the service you want to
provide to your users so that
the service is rela iable always
available in time users
without downtime we comment in the senate in the
keynote  many of google's services
have already exceeded one billion
users including including the
google cloud platform these services
have in common that they run on a
common infrastructure that is not only
similar but also common both in terms
of hardware machines and in terms of
network  both in terms of technologies
google has proposed over the years
many technologies which have been very
influential in the market in the
scientific community and also in the
commercial community as initially maps more
if bigtable and in more recent times
tensions
the vast majority of these
technologies are available today  in the
form of services in the cloud platform  they
generally categorize the services in
storage compute big data and machine
learning
let's see now how then
we solve certain requester of
our applications that have to do
with large amounts of data and how google
cloud allows you developers to
solve the same problems
a problem and for  example being able to
run your services not in the form
of processes can potentially processes
contained in large-scale
containers quickly and efficiently
the solution we have been using in google
for more than a decade is called borg which
has also influenced the construction of
a system  external open source called
gubernatis in the cloud platform
there is a google container
engine service that we say managed version
of big bear netease the characteristics
of google container engine are precisely
an
automatic cluster management of the click day
cluster of process orchestration
a registry is also provided  private
for  allow your docker containers
for example
the developer is also allowed to
explicitly declare the resources that
an application must use and the
system causes these resources to be enforced
that there is an enforcement of these
resources within the class and
also let's say to contain not
has features for auto
scaling if
the application requires it we have
also said that a strong echo arment in the case
of the search engine and large
services and our case of data that must also
scale to levels of  export of
thousands of petabytes
the initial solution used
internally in google is called it was
called google file system which is
about more than five years ago and it was
taken in the solution called
internally colossus the same
solution is available as an
external service under the name of google  cloud
storage cloud storage therefore a
filesystem distributed on an exabyte scale
that guarantees  sce a high throughput and
also guarantees it manages the
replication of the storage both
within the same region and
across different regions.
that are
archived and cost less
to keep archived versus roth data
that must be highly available
in the plans to manage these
history classes are common
also in case you have an
ad hoc application and want to start
using for the storage part
google cloud storage instead 10 and fest
is available a connector is made available
that makes this
porting much simpler this
part that amuses me the most but cares about it
already has already talked about it I
add some details for the
data processing part on  large scale
google has proposed enormously
advanced solutions infl  uents such as mapreduce rivers
uil that have become
a new offer in the cloud platform called
google data from google cloud dataflow
also to guarantee our customers
to be able to develop, let's say, pipelines
to press big data and not
necessarily be blocked in the
google cloud faq platform her  pid
dataflow have been outsourced in a
process in an open source project
called a paci bim which mattia
talked about before which became a top
player project of the pace foundation the
data flow features as
we have seen before we have in the plans
only for both problems from  solve
batch processing problems of
streaming processing the system
provides auto scaling features and in
particular a very powerful feature to
call liquids chardin internally
or the system post is able to
recognize at runtime if a
work segment is taking much longer than
other segments of work and therefore succeeds
din  amicably to respect the work is to
avoid those so-called long
tail problems when they develop when
developing pipelines
that manage large amounts of data
are provided as we have seen before
connectors for the storage solutions
provided by google cloud bic table bqr
cloud storage and as we said  some plans
to write your programs are
actually open source so they can
also be led to use other back
ends to the training and running engine the
back ends as a paci sparkling if
instead our need is to bring
existing clusters for example aduc the
spark and  bring them to the google cloud
platform the solution provided and cloud and
tap rock of the prox supports aduc spark
piguet aiff provides in turn some
connectors habic table b query cloud
storage and as mattia mentioned in
the previous session
you can use these connectors to
save the status of your pipeline
in separate storage this
allows you to ren  give your pipeline
stateless reality which allows you to
pull it up and down dynamically,
saving also levitating and avoiding
waste
also cloud proc provides a
high-level ep so you don't have to worry about
the management and maintenance problems
of the cluster but only about where you are
worry about submitting games
in these to plans and the system will take
over all the rest
on this last point we dwell a
little more if the
file system storage solution is not enough
for your application for example
in case  you need
to access precise data or modify
small portions of data there is a need
for a solution that can keep
the same data at the same scale, let's say
petabyte levels but also allow
punctual read-write access to the
data the main solution we have
in google it is still bit table which is
a system that we say influenced
started everything  the movement of
the so-called no sequel databases is provided
externally as under the name of
google cloud time is a service
completely managed by the
google cloud infrastructure it is indeed
a database we will see in the
next slide what it means in a little
more detail is able  to scale
on petabytes of data while maintaining a low
latency of access to data and degradation
also of scaling in terms of
throughput according to the number of
server nodes associated with the
cluster also of the
very powerful interesting feature of bic table
the service is  able to learn and
automatically re-balance according
to the access patterns we focus
on these points a little
more in detail what it means that it is a
database a sequel in fact means
that your storage can be
represented in a form  tabular
probably the easiest way and
imagine how a bic table
works and how it imagines  re
a somewhat three-dimensional spreadsheet let me explain
better
the data is organized in rows and
for each row there is one and only one
identifying key that uniquely identifies the row
and the number of columns
associated with each row and
also dynamic  given a pair rino column
a cell in short, be the ball allows you
to save if the developer
requests multiple versions of the
same cell so not only
necessarily the latest version of the
data each cell identified by an
integer which in many cases is times as
much but  it can also be at
the developer's discretion the guarantees
of transactionality are limited to the
single row which is an
intuitively limiting thing of bic table but
is in fact the secret why an
overview is able to scale for large amounts of data  of the architecture the clients
find the of the ball note to contact
by passing from a download balancer in the
next slides we will remove that la  yer
for now it is enough to know that it is an
extremely fast process seamless
there is no discovery service included
in this phase the clients are able
to identify
extremely quickly passing by dawn
lancer which bigtable nodes to contact
depending on the portion of the table  who
want to access an embankment is an
interesting aspect of the architecture and that the
north big balls are basically
stateless all the storage a bit like we
recommend you do for your
applications all the storage is saved
on a sistri file actually bu it on
file  system colossus and beat the ball is
not how to say they manage each other
to decide who has access and takes over the
management of different portions of data
also the table is able to dictate
cases in which a node is receiving more
load has more data  in management of
respect to other nodes
ok in the example we see in the slide
the first node is receiving more clients
than other nodes and is ge  I also lay out more
flight life data able to detest
this pattern and rebalance the
load dynamically this operation
generally lasts less than a second or in
any case a few seconds and is
completely transparent from the
cloud side thanks to this balancing feature it
is also possible to
increase  o decrease the number of bit
tables no according to your needs
without generating down time
in the application then as soon as you
add say no from your
cluster the system will automatically
balance the distribution of data and the
clients will automatically find the
new amnesties to contact with
minimal impact  or null on your service
this linear scalability in
let's say in the number of nodes is one of the
strengths of bic table for which
still a technology that
is used both internally to google and
also externally we have observed
a correlation even for large clusters
linear between the number of
nodes and the  load and this thing is still
true when we talk about hundreds of
nodes even in the version of
this cloud next gen
san francisco intervention a case is mentioned
in which in case in which
a number of nodes of 3,500 nodes of bic
table with a  cloud with a
proven flow system of 200 machines with 32
cores that insisted on this data that
finally scaled without stopping
without stopping again without
reaching conciseness so for
very large loads we are talking about millions
tens probably even hundreds of
millions of those depending on  depending on
how shown they are organized bigtable
can scale up if you provide
enough machine and with this I leave
the word to michele who will explain how
me in ad uses some of these
services for their business also explains
what he does to me as a company thanks
michele
ok good
thanks  dario then good morning everyone
thanks for sure to google for
inviting us to pre  hear our
experience in the use
of war cloud tools in the advertising world
basically this is the ecosystem
in which the maìna da company moves I
will then tell you in a few words what
we do more precisely
the ecosystem is given by  a part of the
world of data that more and more are
connected to the world
of
advertising fundamentally today advertising is based on
programmatic technologies from which we also talk a
lot about vertising programmatics
the union of these two worlds should
keep the promise  to show the
correct advertising message to the
correct person at the right time
this is tending to happen in the
world in fact it is not always so menada
works with new google technologies
to solve this type of problem and
therefore also not to bore users
who sometimes receive messages
advertising or too insistent or
not quite in line according to
expectations
how many times ave  you surfed an e-
commerce site and you found yourself receiving
an advertisement for a product that you have
just bought tends to make no
sense it may not make sense how much in
time you may have seen a product
a very complementary and similar service
for example buying a dress  I receive an
advertisement from an
online laundry near my house
this does not yet happen
specifically in the world
of advertising but a
particular company goes to solve these types
of problem
solutions with ad hoc solutions for you
to connect big data
with advertising through
machine learning technologies which are the ones we
have introduced to make a
more predictive analysis with a view to
improving the system that we
manage therefore predictive analysis
means going to identify
as much as possible an advance on the basis
of a series of datasets
which can be the product service in
which mom  ento on Quadri device
present to the user who at that
moment is in front of the browser whether it
is desktop or momail and at that precise
moment in less than 100 milliseconds
we as mine have to decide on the
whole within a
very large dataset certainly of  petabyte
which advertising message to offer to the
user but even if buying that
advertising space minus
the particularity of our company
that we transform the purchase of the
impressions we take care of and
therefore we also take at risk in
a result for the customer who
cira in  a reason from a performance point of view
so we are really
let's say on the edge of the business the
most challenging one we are not a
comfortable situation where we receive an advertising budget it
is simply
we spend it minard an
international company with a history I think
very interesting because it was born in Pescara
10 years ago from there  it has expanded in various
parts of the world putting in addition to the
court of pescara and  at the milan offices
putting 20 engineers in india 20
people who deal with ad operations
in the philippines and then disseminating
many other colleagues to give
customer advice and to manage the
global development and our business
we serve customers who tend to
be multi-country and  has traveled a
story that can be summarized as a
player who has always tried to
adopt technologies or in advance of the unjust
moment this is a bit of
our excursus we started by
focusing on social marketing
when it was actually the
predominant marketing channel then we
developed  of vertical websites to
manage the comparison of products
we entered the world of
programmatic advertising also called
reality and beating and from here we
introduced machine learning solutions
up to branded a new
product that we launched
just recently is called logic which
it also tends to give to the
naming level the meaning of how we want to
approach the system therefore a
predictive analysis where the logic that what
is given by machine learning is
put in step 1 of each activity
normally advertising campaigns
work in this way and in a
somewhat old way I plan  I collect the results
I see the results and then I optimize to
do these things sometimes it is enough to spend
even 24 hours in the best situation
sometimes even 48 hours pass rather
than a week
we need to
immediately have a solution that is as
ideal as possible because not  we have
money to lose on the road which
obviously the better the more the
blending is powered by our data,
therefore in essence
the business side needs of the project that
we have developed together with google
cloud and to which we have given a logical name,
the needs differ in three areas
1 a vision of customizing
technology in a very thorough way for
some  reasons in the meantime because the landscape
of singh freedom is very crowded and
therefore the competition is very high and
we need to find solutions that
distinguish the players to bring
customers the most added value possible
an advertiser and a merchant that you do
commerce does not use a single partner but
uses  10 15 20 partners who
contribute to its final result
so the better you are the more precise you are
and the more you can scale up on business volumes
then we actually wanted to
ask ourselves a question on how to operate
the data in a more predictive logic to
you the business of the TV
advertising program a very fast virus and a
business where the impressions and
advertising spaces are available at
the moment or maybe they are not
available in a moment so having
a predictive logic immediately available
we needed to start
optimizing immediately  to the activities and then
we wanted to work in a logic of
single instance and therefore no longer
r  act in terms of target how many
times if you are a little close to the world of
marketing you think in terms of
targets which are obviously
interesting but very simplifying arguments
men women residing here or there do not
however indicate the
specific characteristic of the user
I michele this  morning i
connected i made a certain journey from
home to milan of this information
my device is full of it we
also use this information to
go and do
georeferencing activities rather than on the
basis of my navigation within
the abc brand site
we can say those users who are more akin to
receiving an advertisement from the user
abc therefore
the projects on the business side the needs given
business are those technology
dhabi costumes predictive analysis and work
on the single room or here or on the
single user
in essence to do that  what this is
the last slide and step with the word
culio for more  tell the
current technical speeches better decisions
because as we said
before there is the importance of
giving the user a current relevant message
of the best decisions that
are also from a core saving perspective
when our system is called
logical yes  is faced with a
decision to purchase an
advertising space immediately processes
information
such that it may deem it
inappropriate to purchase that advertising space based
on the return
on investment of that
advertising space this then reflects
our business model we
purchase advertising and  we get
paid for them by customers based on the
results and then a
pasteurized message the personalized message
is more relevant than ever in order to
effectively enter into a logic of
engagement with the user
the advantages of the project have
turned into the wire mans that
describes culio  this side of our and
analysts  but here it is happy to pass
[Applause]
hi, I'm the culio I came from under
aprini I have to apologize because I will not do
the presentation in English and in
Italian to be done in English justin
gatlin of rwe quest one and extra art
space opened with sandals these months
a  parte risapute io so right side of
the place mendatica website dei tag
comes in database in modo soft
architecture be able to reply animated
by take that a pencil mount six were
romanians of the canals educated win some
tendons application by tim golden state
a grind the logic side  of the moon
[Music] it is
therefore logical that right from ring data
processing gone publishing science day
time in analysis side table state
appetita data analysis team of tt games
hub data from bimbaite guide pro mayor
putin place in the owls b automatic
default sheet provide  golden state
a wind day
he too pine Italians fina veni veni
this both on the part
that tends to explain and possibly
on the archite  ttura di maina de you can
also reach us we are here or close to the
tastes there if you have questions to ask
we say in private
thank you very much thanks to bulleri that good
continuation
day everyone I see that you are still
returning so we wait a few
seconds
in the meantime a chance to
introduce me maybe you have seen  first i
'm mattia poletti i'm a customer
engineer who works on the google cloud
in my spare time i fake
credit cards as you probably noticed
this morning what i want to
talk about today is a little different than
what we saw this morning is
instead going a bit  more in detail and
talk to you and show you the
google solutions that allow you to tackle the
problems related to big data
share a big word the word we
often hear and with which we often deal
in everyday work
we want to show you how google can
help you with  your technologies maybe
we take a step back before that
we can define how big big
data is in fact in reality it is a
fluid concept and a concept that
obviously changes depending on when we are in the
period but these are some numbers
that maybe really make it clear how
big and are actually a number of a
couple of d  'years ago so they are even
bigger than what happens on the internet
in a minute there is a huge amount of data
that is generated a huge amount of
data that must be managed analyzed
and this also in the walls in
the company perimeter in the perimeter
company data can be generated can
come from different sources here we have
identified four that should
cover as a category I think the
main ones first of all there are the data
that you already analyze
historically you already have in the company and
analyzed then there are data that you
probably collect collect
but  that you have not yet analyzed in line there
is some data that you could collect
but that you do not yet do is obvious  mind then
there are also data, let's say external to
the company perimeter which are data that
could come from partners or third
parties as you can imagine the sum of
all these data which in fact
always increases over time is enormous and
to manage them there are some  challenges
and there are
the problems that every company has to
face here we want to make you
understand how google can help you the
first is that obviously it is difficult to
develop pipeline data pipeline with
pipe line
I mean essentially the fact that the
data is collected from some
source are processed  transformed
are then written to another in
another destination probably for
analysis and evaluation of sorts
this process requires technologies and
to develop these processes these
technologies is often complicated the first
step of this development of
these pipelines usually arises from
that  which is called data preparation
ie i of the data probably i  n home
wherever they are and often these data
could be dirty they
could be redundant they could
have any kind of problems and
often in creating these pipelines
this process the data preparation
takes a long time requires many
work cycles which are often
unproductive because simply
preparing data  that are not ready
to be used on this google
has recently privately released
a very useful tool that now I
would like to show you avoiding
gesturing too much as we will do it we will
do it essentially imagining a
case a use case in case of use where we
imagine ourselves  being a retail company
that has an online advertising network
where it receives ad impressions
then clicks on its advertising banners
that bring traffic to its site
and then this traffic generates
sales then generates transactions
so we have two sets of data as you can see here
the first being the between  nsations
of sales and second instead that are the
clicks that have generated the traffic
what we want to correlate is to
correlate understand how a click can
have generated a sale and therefore
we must highlight that id you
see selected here which is
essentially a unique id for a
single  product available on the
website on the website
now I go to the demo that I show
how the dataset works essentially they
are of two types are one is a table
inside the glasses that we have
mentioned this morning and the others are very
simple csv this the
cloud interface  at opens for the first thing
you have to do you have to create a flow a
flow is simply a construct
within which there are all the
operations we are going to do the first
thing that suggests us how you see to
add these datasets that I
obviously  I have already prepared the first 6
scales is a table on bqr then a
classic table and the other a non csv I
add them here  then inside my data
flow of mine sorry my flop is
loading them and automatically the tour
recognizes these two data sets it
understands for example the information
that is inside these datasets it
even has in the csv obviously it finds
and reads it  showing already what are the
columns within this data set it
starts working on the query table
to do this what I have
to do I have to add a new recipe because
inside the data for the algorithm
let's say of data preparation is
called recipe  or in Italian
recipe point the first thing we notice from
this point of view of the toula itself is
that the graphic tool is therefore not a tool
where I have to abstract the concept didactic
are squares various things arrows that
often does not make it easy it is very
similar to  spreadsheet
spreadsheet however more works precisely on big
data
as you see this here and there and the list
of transactions that we have in
particular us there  interests without order
lines so the single transactions
when you see also we also see an array
and an array inside which there
are jayson files of jason files that
are typically difficult to read
inside kosovari jason there is the one
of which  I was talking to you first
what I do by simply
selecting the column I receive from the tour
as you can see below some
transformation suggestions already automatically
understands what to do and proposes
things obviously puts a bit of criterion
and I try to understand which is the most
suitable in this case  I see several
scrolls and I see that what
interests me is to convert this array
this vector into single
rows automatically above
you see that a new column has been created
and this column contains every
single jayson file among other things
visually ordered much more  easy if
you remember we must find this
product identifier the product
is within this camp  o and it's
called product key what I do I
simply underline it and
underlining again the tool comes
to my aid and automatically understands what
is inside this thing and
suggests me for example the simplest thing
which is to extract from whom
from the
from the sorry from the dl dataset sorry
little problem tag a second that I
have not saved the other part ok
because what you forget to do
add it to the recipe so
I added the passage that I
told you before the recipe
now I go back to what you  I was
telling and what I essentially have to do
is simply
add the field that is now
obviously blocked that I told you
before that it was this here
suggests me to extract if the sword air
directly from the line sorry ok and
this suggestion to extract this
this value  it is done I add the
recipe done this thing as I
said I have to go back to the
other dataset on which I was there  wanting
then I change the data 7 step
within the data set of the csv also
here there are various information as
you can see regarding the
advertising banners that I saw we said before is
what I am interested in seeing here for
example to which many see use of
as you see c  'it is a very
fair distribution except for one value if I
select this value what
happens is that it lists me only this
value which ends as I would use them of 666 I
select the cells that the rows which are
relative to this user which is therefore the
one that ends  with 666
and I notice that the 20 then the wind of
click of this user is one every
second probably this I think it
tells me it simply tells me that it is not a
human being clicking once every
second but it is a bot
so I what I do
simply remove by changing  then
the transformation you see that it becomes
red I remove all these lines
and I add the recipe also in this
case to these lines essential  lly
the other thing disappeared as I told you was we have to
extract the word ai of the clique that
occur within this dataset
so I focus on the rl inside it
is he a rl as you can see there is
a code we are looking for  in this
case he selected it from 1l at random as
you can see here also
suggestions appear suggestions to
extract that certain number that
certain number but obviously it is not
the specific one I am interested in but it is a
pattern to what I am looking for and
therefore I try to give a  suggestion
maybe a little stronger in the selection
another I also select this
this value you understand that the tool begins
to better understand the pattern I am
suggesting and looking in the various
transformations I see that this is the most
suitable i.e. extract after the same and
at the end  of this rl, however, I want to
make this signal even stronger
and maybe in place that puts a dream an
equal I also add the keyword pd
because appu  nto I want to
make this thing stronger I simply
add the recipe and as you can see
a column is generated that I now
call in rename in product heidi
that I add the recipe and
then I extracted both from a dataset and
from the other the products  to what I am missing
now as an activity I simply merge
two datasets and then to do
this I simply apply a
joint transformation the selection and
select the other dataset I was working on I
open this dataset you see that it is the
dataset I was working on before  and I
get joint kisses automatically the tool
suggests me for example to merge the
user ids with cast mark king
the other thing that interests me because
I want to essentially evaluate the effect
of when a click has generated a
sale then I can select levent i'm
so when there was the click and
on the other side the order dates what
I do also in this case I add
this transformation  to joint on these
certain joint keys with the fields
that interest me at the exit of this
young woman
do this thing or tile the table that
interests me is the last step that
I could do
and simply try to understand the
time difference so I don't have to
I calculate by hand I select the
two columns relative to the time again
I get results that are
suggestions on the transformations in
this case I see that here it suggests me
to create a column with the heat
dif
then the time difference between a
factor and l  'other is also here I add
the recipe made this thing what
I could do simply launch the
job now I do not show it
obviously would become very long
had simply what happens is
that what I have done here at a
theoretical level instead of sel  done on that
small Tehran dataset 5 megabytes of
sample will then be done on any
type of data size by
creating  job of sweaty flow jobs that
precisely create those pipe lines
I was discussing before
let's go back to the slides ok perfect ok
because you can't go on to
whoever swiss life
ok
the other part was telling you precisely
in the rest of the pipelines but here I have
some problems and  one that can change
lies nothing ok then if you come back here
I can show the slide
directly to the yes
be patient there is a small
technical problem and they restart everything in case
this with the presentation I will also show it to you
I attach the cable and the  I
show directly today I am
unlucky with technology it seems to me
you have patience or according to someone has
some questions in the meantime so as not to
waste the time because I am
always available to ask questions
no one is okay then part at the bottom
that is ok perfect please someone owes you
I beg
nothing today the technology is hostile to us
gasol
you know
there is gray
oh how nice to come back we made it
and fortunately present it  action also
on my laptop always always positive the
thing I will do a little shorter however you have
seen then the first part which was the
data preparation and how these tools
can help to create the data
protection the next part which was the
one below that is the
data preparation tool underlies the model
underlying the former closed nanjing which
resides under data plath and data flow and
often developing these pipelines these
execution engines is complex and
above all because we say two models
that are historical institutes in the
way of developing the  big data pipelines
that are not perfect the first is the
classic approach butch the
brace approach born above all due to the fact that
the tools did not lose support
a more realistic approach which
was streaming and the other thing that
even in streaming events often
come  therefore considered when
many events arrive they are
considered in the moment of recession
in the moment of creation  ion data flow
allows you to address this problem
and how it does it with the help of a
tool especially for the
streaming part which is called google maps ab
publishing subscribe in what it
essentially does is a queue that is
distributed globally that allows you to
receive huge  quantity of
incoming messages organized by topic and
allows you to always read them
an organization by topic by
topic by different subscribers
so this is a tool that
really allows you to
scale on the order of hundreds of
thousands of events per second with just a few clicks
imagine the streaming model
where it receives this information and
then passes it the pipelines from the data flow
data flow allows you to create a
much more interesting programming model
because it supports these 22
use cases above all to the
unified programming model that is, it supports both
the one that the other also together and this
has an advantage because for  puts in fact
to discover real use cases very very
interesting even that data flow
born as a google project
within google
has become an open source project with the
name of apache bim a model
an open source apache ibim project that
allows you to use the  same
conceptual approach, however, by exploiting
not only the data flow pipelines that
are typical of the google cloud but
also wanting other typical execution engines in the
world in the big data world such as for
example a paci spark or a paci apex
or others the other problem is related
instead  to the problem of the fact that even
having these tools you imagine that
you also feel good states in the
classical world to develop all these
tools
then go from the proof of
concept situation maybe a real production with the
real numbers that you could have in
your reality is very difficult to
scaling these solutions is difficult and
this comes at a cost to the company due to the
fact that all that ope  The ability
to manage these systems alone
to scale them to the dimensions that are necessary
requires a lot of time and effort, i.e.
there are a whole series of activities that
have no value because the only
activity that really has value is
that instead of analysis and extraction
of  valid information from this mass
of data with our tools you can
do this and you can do it
effectively because, as you can see here in
this small image, often passing
by the more you have a production, maybe you
try to use the same tool
for something that does not  it is suitable as
this poor child's paddle to
make a hole inside a
beach to show you this concept i
show you a b query demo of
those our analytic engine where
essentially you can put huge
amounts of data inside this
of this analytical engine and
interrogate them with truly
incredible speed to show you what I am
doing v  edere I show this
table is an already loaded dataset whose
characteristic is to be a table
of 1.09 petabytes and a
billion trillion rows a huge amount
now then we will think what this means
what we are going to do simply
let's go and do  a query a very
simple query where what we want to do is
identify all the rows from these
trillion rows relative to a
certain order relative to a
certain if I know arcs that it is not
exactly the same thing
I what I have to do as  you see a
very simple classic sql query I launch
the query the query wait for me to do it
again because if not this is not right
because it essentially showed you
the sloppy version the query
will practically go on all
these times today patience this one
will essentially go on all remove  the
results text because otherwise it
would take a lot less
now launch it I let it go now it
will take a  po because obviously we are
talking about a petabyte it usually
takes 14 minutes and therefore from the tele the
problems we have had up to
now probably we will not have time and
see it immediately but after I speak it will
allow you to show how long it
took me for while it works  while
running this query let's
imagine how big a
petabyte is a petabyte is the same
amount of data that would fit in
a floppy disk stack at high as 12
empire state building
or is it the amount of data that
download ste in 27 years of  4g connection
or they are 100 library of the congress
in washington or they are fifty
times all the tweets ever tweeted from
twitter but even a small petabyte
a petabyte is very small because it is
the equivalent of two micrograms of DNA
is the equivalent of a single day of
videos uploaded to youtube is
the ilog equivalent of 200 servers that
generate 50 entries every second for three
years
if you see the last two  examples you can
imagine how these are related to
the google world so we have always
had to think and work on
data dimensions concerning the
petabyte
and this is witnessed precisely by the
fact that what happened with
google is that having to work on this
scale
we have always searched  to develop
technologies for us first of all this
we have been doing it for some time because
essentially
these solutions could not be found on the market
we started in the early
2000s with the google file system we
then evolved it with algorithms and technologies such
as mapreduce that  then they gave
rise to aduc for example in the market
through a paper the development of beat the
ball which we talk about in others in other
sessions up to dremel dremel
essentially is the internal name of
glasses we obviously developed
for a case of use to analyze
the  huge amount of logs from our
servers you can imagine how many serves
we have e  then once
we did this we decided to
expose it and make it available to
companies by also increasing the use cases
that this can cover in fact
bqr is now what it is called
looking at the process server the es
datawarehouse covers all  the classic use cases
of a data warehouse with this
amazing feature that you
can do the same the one
we are waiting for results on a
ten-row table or a
trillion-row table that you don't
have to change anything
in the infrastructure  it is exactly the
same thing
and also the advantage that you pay only
what you consume so from pio xi
up to production does not change
anything at all
now it owed a harley but I already know that
it is not finished yet because it takes those
four minutes
in the meantime I turn on the lights  last two
things I want to talk about before moving
on to debre and the other big problem
always in the field of big data is that
often i  data are segregated segregated
in single silos and even this
the google architecture allows you to
be don't tell me it happened new and
easier no nothing even this today
the gods of whatever there is
the google architecture allows you to
help you  because because it makes a
very important concept that the separation of
processing with storage that is the
technologies that I have
told you about so far that deal
with data processing are
decoupled from the technologies that
deal with data storage and
each of the technologies  of processing
can interact independently with
each of the storage technologies
allowing you to really
cross data and do processing that is
normally very complicated where you
do it hidden in the data copy them give
access via connectors and so on
the last point not least important
obviously the fact that  having created
prepared the data having processed them  and
transformed according to what we need by
having integrated with other data sources
last classic point is
the analysis and visualization also on
this google offers
solutions are two different solutions for
different use cases the first is data lab
that  it is essentially an
electronic notebook for data scientists where
they can create their own rhythms they can
interrogate the various
processing engines we have told you about they
can write code visualize
and elaborate according to their
techniques of their needs, even
perhaps based on concepts of  machine
learning that we talk team deep and in-
depth but very in-
depth in another session and
the other instead is much more aimed at
the business analyst data studio is what
it essentially does and
allows you to create business
dashboards dashboard interactive visualization
of case data  use different but no less
important with this invitation m on the stage  o
emmer e il city o di cube it who is one of
us is a customer of ours who uses
these solutions every day
to analyze billions of data
in the meantime that passes him with second and
has finished b query yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeahs a me lo  I show after the
eyes after
how many
ok ami ias good morning it's a pleasure to
be here
thanks to all thanks to google my name is i am i
would like to speak italian today but
please excuse me because
technology is better described in english
for me today i tell you about jobs
[  Music]
technologies investments
[Music]
all
providers in store
of wild and be seen from that work
[Music]
using the day before we are using the
smartphone google of business
[Applause]
these questions I don't know how we are those
times if the energy gives me a signal but
gladly take questions either on
the shadows part or on the more part of
google itself if there was a question before there
that we have not been able
to take  and I do not see when I changed my
mind yes self answered fantastic nothing
if no one to questions we wait what is
someone no nothing
I would say that we can thank you for your
presence and of course the next
sessions that there are both here and
in the other of football
thanks  thousand
[Applause]